[Music]
i would like to welcome
[Applause]
alicia
hi my name is alicia schapp and i'll be
talking to you today about
auto magic package development or an
effort to build a vega
a vegalite interface in r that i call vl
builder
and if you're interested in the package
at the end this
the github page is under the vega widget
organization
and in the readme to the package there
is a link to the slides
for this presentation now an alternate
title i could have come up with here if
i had a more literary bent would be
a tale of two pr's because a lot of this
work was motivated by
a pr several years ago and recently
vindicated by
another one and i'll be sharing about
both of those
in this talk i want to start off first
though talking about a little off topic
about
gigi plot 2 because digipot 2 is what
originally sold me on r
i had in programming in python before i
learned r and i thought it was kind of
awkward kind of weird
but gigi platoon was amazing i could do
all of these things once i learned those
basic building blocks
learned that underlying grammar i could
also make all these different kinds of
plots
and it felt really powerful and really
special and so over the years even as i
you know oscillated between using python
and r i would always come back to r for
the visualization part because gg plot 2
was just so good and in my opinion
nothing in python are really quite
measured up but that recently has
changed and
python i feel like can now compete in
the visualization domain and that's
because of a package called alt-hair
if you use python at all i highly
recommend checking it out it's really
amazing
developed by jake vanderplost and brian
granger and a whole team of folks
um and is you know still under active
development and uh really well
maintained
and it is like ggplot2 in many ways it
it's
it's under it's built on top of a
grammar of graphics
so it has some of the same properties
that you know once you learn the basic
patterns
you can all of a sudden make all sorts
of different kinds of visualizations
but it has in some ways even more powers
than gg plot 2
because it enables you to make
interactive graphs this is an example of
a graph
made by altair just taken literally from
the altera example gallery
where you know you're plotting uh in one
graph like temperature over the year in
seattle
but then when you like pan and brush you
can see the different types of
precipitation status
over those time ranges and this all
looks very complicated but an altair
actually makes this very easy because it
has those basic building blocks which
you can easily tie together to make
something like that so it's not this
isn't you know
if you're trying to make this in like d3
it would probably like take
well at least take me like a year and
many thousands of lines of code
in in altair this is just a little bit
of python code
and the reason it's so powerful is that
altair is built on top
of vega light which implements this
interactive grammar of graphics
vegalite itself is a higher level
abstraction built on top of something
else
vega and all this was developed by the
interactive data lab at the university
of washington
and just as a quick uh you know i'll be
using some terms in this talk just as
quick
gg plot to vega like terminology
translations
imagine much more of you are familiar
with gigi plot than vagalite
in ngplot where you'd call talk about a
geom that's a mark an aesthetic it's an
encoding a stat as a transform
but it has a lot of the same underlying
concepts
vegalite is in javascript and it uses a
json specification
to tell the plot what to what to draw
and how to what what should be the mark
what should be the encoding and so on
um so if you actually try to make a plot
this way it can get a little bit
uh clunky like building sort of nested
lists
isn't like the most uh fun way to
program it can be a little
you know and you have where exactly do
you have to put all your curly braces
and all
and this is where a package like altair
is really powerful because it builds an
api on top of that so you don't have to
worry too much
about that complicated nested list you
can just use some
ordinary python methods to build up that
plot
there's also now in javascript a nice
api to
to build up those those plots called
vega lite api
and in a number of different languages
there are really great
packages so what i want is an r api for
making vega like charts that
hopefully is of a similar caliber to
some of those other ones that i just
mentioned and now some of you might be
thinking well
hasn't there been a on our package
that's even called vega light for many
years and you're absolutely right and it
has
it's developed it was developed by bob
brudus and it is a in many ways a really
great package it provides a really nice
api
where you know it uses the pipe that
people are so familiar with
where you can you know iteratively build
up components of this plot
the thing is it ha it's not up to date
with some of the latest and greatest
vega light features
including some of those really killer
features like the interactivity and the
view composition where you can put
different subplots together and the
reason
it's not necessarily up to date is
because it's actually you know when you
build
this sort of interface to this other
thing it can be kind of hard to update
over time because
it's vega light is is pretty big at this
point and so
trying to to keep it up to date is a
pretty big endeavor
and i know that because i actually tried
to update this package
so many years ago so i told you this
would be a tale of two pr's this is
that first one i would talk about um
and so i wanted to you know the packages
at vega light 1.0 i want to update it to
valet 2.0 and spin so i spent
quite a lot of time like going through
and this was a massive pr so just
pro tip if you're a first time
contributor to package this is not what
you should do
this is like exactly like the opposite
of what you should do like i changed 88
files and like 48 000 or something lines
of code
uh it would you know it took a while for
it to actually get accepted it did
eventually make its way in
but you know one of the things i learned
was like this took a lot of work and
like the thing is
that the vega like developers are really
productive they're continuing to make
improvements and so
like this method of like trying to keep
this r api
in in in line with this vega
this changing vega light definitions was
just going to be
a herculean task so i stepped back
i was like okay maybe i'll focus on
other things
but then out of the blue someday i got
an email from ian
little and he was embarking on a new
effort which was to actually make
a port to vega life through altair
using the reticulate package so in some
ways a little funny
using you know python to get to
javascript but it actually works really
well and he was working in uh
with haley jepson and heike hoffman from
iowa
and um and this package is now on cran
it's also available here at bigger
widget
altair and so i was really excited by
this effort and
i got involved it gets started to chip
into that package
um and i think my biggest contribution
was actually
suggesting to ian that maybe
he could split off one part of the
package into something else which is
that it was using altair to you know
use some code to make that specification
for what the chart should be
but then another big part of the code
was just taking that specification
and rendering in an r so you could
actually see the plot and i said well
maybe we should make that a separate
package to just do the render so that
became the vega widget
package so vega widget just takes a json
spec
and then uses the html widgets package
in r to turn it into a plot
and this was primarily developed by ian
who actually at this very minute
is giving a talk in another room which
is kind of
unfortunate timing but
you know he's a really smart very nice
guy you should check
you should go find him and talk to him
if you're interested in any of this
stuff
um and myself and stuart lee helped with
some of the
um javascript uh functionality in this
package
and so what this package also does is it
provides interfaces from that html
widget
to other parts of the art ecosystem in
particular shiny so it has
functions to help you listen to events
to connect to
what invago world is called a signal
which is basically a dynamic data value
and also to let you update the data
that's in the plot without completely
re-run doing it
what vega widget doesn't do is it
doesn't help you make the spec so
you know if you it basically expects
some json to be given to it which in our
form
is going to be basically a big
complicated nested list
so this isn't a package that you're
usually going to want to use directly
you're not going to want to go and make
this kind of list because it's a little
bit clunky and you'd have to know
and you'd have to store in your head
exactly how to make this kind of thing
but this package is designed to be a
helper to other packages
that where those other packages would
help you make the spec and then
they can rely on the shared interface to
actually render it
so one of those packages is that the an
r
port the altair package which is uses
altair via articulate to actually make
that spec and then gets rendered
ian and haley and others are now working
on gg vega which is a package
to take a ggplot object turn it into one
of those specs
and then have it render and then i've
been working
on vl builder which is basically in some
ways like a spiritual successor to that
vega light package which develop tries
to make a native r api
to make these specs which then can be
rendered via vega widget
so the goals of vl builder were they
wanted like a pipe friendly approach for
building up vega light specs one
something that felt sort of natural to
an
r user who might be familiar with the
tidy verse
i want to stay pretty close to the vega
light spec so like not
not inventing new abstractions not
inventing new terminology but just kind
of
taking what what is in vega light and
and making it accessible in our
but maybe a little syntactic sugar here
and there for when you have common
things to do that might be a little
clunky i'm trying to make those a little
easier
another key thing i wanted was to have
auto complete and documentation help
so that you know if you're trying to add
an encoding you can see what are the
different parameters i can give to that
and that's something that actually is a
little bit missing from the altair
package
because it's going through articulate
you kind of end up having to really use
it effectively you often have to end up
going to the python docs
they're not quite as easy to access
um for an r user in in our studio
and then the most important thing or in
my mind developing this was that it had
to be fun to develop
and easy to update as the vegalized
schema evolved because i learned from
that other pr that like
you know if you just you know try to
build something up manually
um that tries to match vega light
it's going to take a lot of work when
vega light up evolves
and i didn't want to get caught in that
same bind again
so here i took inspiration from altair
and the vegalite api packages
because both of those approaches in in
python and javascript respectively
um actually auto-generate big parts of
their api
using vega light itself so they vagalite
has a schema which you can derive
what uh what a a vega like specification
should look like
you can use that um to build up an api
so i thought why don't i try to do this
in r2 so just to go a little bit
more into like what a schema is and what
i mean by that uh
the vagalite schema is basically telling
you in that like kind of json that list
object where you're
you're specifying the different parts of
the plot what is an acceptable
sort of format for each of those parts
so for example
you know you might say here an aggregate
can be one of these other three types
and then
this type can be one of these 12
different values
hopefully it also includes descriptions
for what different fields mean so in
terms of trying to build up the
documentation
a lot of what you want is documentation
is actually embedded
in this schema document
and so the approach i took for building
an r api from a json schema
was one of semi automation so early on i
was like oh maybe i'll try to automate
it as much as possible
but at some point like making something
very generalized and totally automated
becomes
a very hard problem and so i try to
strike the right balance between using
some human curation
and some argument automation so the
human curation part is sort of
identifying what families of functions
do i want so i know that
you know you know an encoding is going
to be a very important part
of to make a vegalite spec i'm going to
want a bunch of different functions that
let you add different kinds of encoding
i'm also going to want that for a mark
so the markers are like the geometry
so i want like a vl mark point vl mark
bar vl mark line etc and so i'm going to
want all these different kinds of
families of functions and they're going
to have this kind of format
but in terms of figuring out exactly
which ones i need
and what's going to go inside them what
are the acceptable parameters
there i'm going to use automation i'm
going to pull those things
out of the schema and plot them into my
function
rather than doing that manually by
copying and pasting i'm going to write
functions to do that
and so all this sort of functions to
build these functions lives in that
package within my package so
if you look in vl builder there's a
build directory and inside of that
there's a package i call vl meta builder
which is the package that builds vl
builder
um and the main function is one that's
called just
create api and it takes as an argument
the schema so as the schema updates
as there's a new version of that schema
i can give it that new version and i'll
create a new api
and so like as an example of like how to
make a family of functions i have
in that create api function called
something called create encoding
functions which will make all those
encoding functions
it first will pull all the possible
encoding so it'll
take a function that says okay this is
where in the schema i'm going to look
for them
and has a function to then pull out all
the different options that would be
available
it then iterates through all of them
and makes the appropriate functions and
so here actually i make sort of
for each encoding i want both the
function that also add one to spec
or one that just makes that object on
its own and then you can see there's
some deprecation so i have even
functions to generate my deprecated
versions of
my of my functions as well um
and so here in terms of the what what a
function to make
a function is here i'm um i have my
create encoder function i call it
another function
because a lot of them actually you know
share a lot of property so i have a
generalized make function
function that takes in most importantly
where to look in the schema so this is a
path to a particular place in that
specification
for what can go in a particular part of
a vega like
a speck and it looks like what are all
the available options and there's a
couple extra things where i specify
as you can tell like one thing that gets
used a lot in this effort is glue the
glue packages
is really handy for this kind of effort
because you know you're basically trying
to make
a bunch of strings where you're putting
different pieces together so that that
has come in really handy in this effort
and so then
it ends up making a function that also
has documentation
because it actually pulls all those
little pieces of documentation out of
that schema object and so i don't have
to
write any of it i can just use what's
already been created
but make it accessible in r in a way
that the you know the r user doesn't
have to go to some website they can just
type in help and get it right there
in in their our studio pane and this is
just one of hundreds of functions
generated by vm
meta builder now this was recently this
package and the approach i took was
recently put to the test
because in december vega light 4 came
out
which added new features new transforms
um and and so there was like okay well
now you know previously i've been using
vega light 3 to generate my api
i want to make it compatible with
version four
hopefully my automation will just take
care of it and i could just
sit back and relax and that actually did
come
to bear so it was another large pr
this time to my own repository which
helps a little bit
but um but
you know behind the sort of numbers that
you know 190 files changed and
tens of thousands of lines of code there
was actually very little work on my part
this took just like literally like an
hour or two one day
like i you know when i first put in the
new schema
one thing broke i fixed that and then
all of a sudden it kind of just
worked and i felt really uh having gone
through that earlier
experience really great um and and you
can kind of see that in some of the more
detailed
descriptions that uh github will give
you
so like in terms of all those lines of
code changing
a lot of them were actually just in the
schema file that gets included in the
repository itself but then the other
thing is i have this file called
auto-gen api
which is all what gets auto-generated by
vl meta builder
and lots of stuff changed there but in
most of my other files
very little um changed and then in terms
of which files were changing actually a
lot of the files changing
where the documentation files which all
pretty much all are being like sort of
auto-generated
through other generated oxygen
documentation
so you know if you're ever finding
yourself writing a bunch of repetitive
functions and documentations which can
often happen
when you're writing a wrapper package um
i'd recommend writing another package to
write your package it can actually end
up being
less work for you down the road
now of course i'm not the only one
that's had this idea other folks have
have you know put in place efforts to
auto generate code and r
so miles just recently asked a question
about whether people were doing this and
there was a great thread of
different people who who were doing this
and he put
some of those suggestions into place
into a package he's developing
there's also a scaffolder package that's
being developed that i think is actually
trying to be a much more
general solution to this which i'm
really excited about
about that package and other efforts in
this vein
and so finally i just want to leave you
with a little bit of a
reminder that this whole vega widget
ecosystem exists
in r if you're interested in making
interactive graphics using vega light
and r
i recommend checking it out at this
point the altera and vega widget
packages are fairly mature they're both
on cran
the other packages are a little bit
still more experimental
and there's a great community of people
involved in these efforts
there's also i think opportunity for new
apis if you're itching to make a higher
level api
for interactive graphics i think the
vega widget package
makes it easy makes that effort easier
because if you can just make that vega
light spec
it can then do the whole rendering part
and so i'm really excited to
potentially see more experimentation in
this space
because i think that yeah the vega
widget package makes that kind of
experimentation possible
and so yeah that is my talk and if
you're interested
again i'll point you to github where the
package lives as well as all those
packages
live in that vega widget organization on
github
and the link to those slides is in the
readme for vl builder
you